PROFESSOR: There is an
effective potential,
as it's described here.
Yes, there is a potential,
the central force,
but if there is
angular momentum,
it's like a centrifugal barrier.
With angular momentum
it becomes very
difficult to reach the origin.
Because if you want
to reach the origin,
you have to spin
faster and faster.
So it becomes very hard
to reach the origin.
And this is like a
repulsive potential here.
So you have an
effective potential.
You started with
just a potential,
the central potential,
but that will
become an effective potential.
This whole thing in
brackets over there
is sometimes called the
effective radial potential.
And it's this V of r plus h
squared over 2mr squared l
times l plus 1.
So if you have a
Coulomb potential,
that would try to
make the electrons go
all the way to the proton.
This is attractive.
Well, even that is not
problematic for l equals 0.
But for l different from
0, you have to add here
a potential that diverges.
And it's positive, say,
for some l positive
and falls off very fast because
forms of like r squared, this,
the Coulomb potential
falls off at 1/r.
So when you combine the
two, so this is just
the centrifugal barrier,
but you combine the two,
this diverges faster as
well, so the total potential
is something like
that in between.
And then you can
have bound states.
And all the theorems we've
learned about bound states
and eigenstates of
one-dimensional potential, now
you discover that they're very
useful in three dimensions.
Many things just carry through.
So this is effective potential.
And it's going to
recap and remember
that the solution that
you've written is Re.
But Re is u of r over r
Y lm of theta and phi.
And one more thing that
I want you to realize,
does the function u depend on l?
Yes.
The differential
equation depends on l.
Does the function u depend on m?
Yes or no?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No.
There's no m in the
differential equation,
so that should be good enough.
So what's happened
is the m dependence
is kind of very simple,
always very simple.
It is the e to the im
phi and nothing else.
The u doesn't know about it.
On the other hand,
the u depends on l
because it shows in the
differential equation.
So I could write here of e
and l because it depends on l,
and it is the solutions of
the Schrodinger equation
in one potential.
So there will be
quantization of energy,
or there might be
stationary states
that depend on the energy.
So this is the function
that knows about l,
knows about the energy.
And we've been
totally successful
with the angular dependence.
Yes.
STUDENT: That should
be theta and phi, dy?
PROFESSOR: Yes, theta and phi.
Thank you.
Good.
Normalization, the last thing
that has to work out nicely.
Let's try to see what
does the normalization say
about this function.
Well, we should find
that the integral of psi
squared d cubed x is equal to 1.
But that integral,
as you now know,
it's the integral of r
squared dr from 0 to infinity.
And how do you
integrate over volume?
You integrate over r.
That has the right units.
And you integrate over
solid angle, d omega.
Of psi squared, so let's
do the arithmetic here.
We have a Y lm star of theta and
phi, a Y lm of theta and phi.
We have a u squared
and then r squared.
Poor graph.
But anyway, you can read it.
Now, what happens
is just good stuff.
r squared cancels.
And this solid
angle angle integral
is a perfect integral
for our normalization.
So this gives you 1.
And therefore the end
result for all this integral
is just the integral from 0 to
infinity of dr u of r squared.
And that must be equal to 1.
So not only is little
u a nice variable
that satisfies a one-dimensional
Schrodinger equation,
but you can remember that
your more complicated wave
function will be normalized
if u is normalized
in the one-dimensional sense.
If u squared integrated
over x is equal to 1, yes,
you're normalized.
So the set-up to convert the
three-dimensional differential
equation into a one-dimensional
differential equation
has been very successful.
We've reduced it to a
one-dimensional problem.
We have to solve those.
Each time somebody gives
you a spherical potential,
you look at that equation,
the radial equation,
and try to solve for u's.
If you solve for
u's, then you can
append the angular
dependents that
correspond to angular
momentum eigenstates.
We call this angular
moment eigenstates.
They are the most you can
ask from angular momentum.
And then you have
many solutions.
So I want to conclude
that part of the analysis
by mentioning something
about solutions
with the appropriate
boundary conditions.
We have x, in the
one-dimensional problem
we call it x.
And you'd run from minus
infinity to infinity.
The one difference here
is that you have r,
and r runs from 0 to infinity.
So you may wonder if you have
some issues with r going to 0.
What should the wave
function do when r goes to 0?
OK.
Then the way we think about
it is not completely general
but is good enough.
We think of the
differential equation
as we have here and
imagine a potential
that when r goes to 0, the
centrifugal barrier dominates.
So our potential of the
form 1 over r to the fourth
would be even more
singular than the barrier.
And I don't know what
happens in that case.
Most likely it's no
good, not interesting.
You cannot find solutions.
But if the potential, like
the Coulomb potential,
is weaker than the centrifugal
barrier as r goes to 0,
the centrifugal barrier
dominates when r goes to 0.
And this differential
equation, as r goes to 0,
has a potential infinite
term which corresponds
to the centrifugal barrier.
So we think of this
as r goes to 0,
the differential
equation roughly
becomes minus h squared over
2m d second u dr squared
plus h squared l times l plus 1
over r squared of u, roughly 0.
At least the leading
behavior of these things
should work out correctly.
So the h squareds--
here is a 2m, as
well, I'm sorry.
The h squared over 2m's
cancel, and you get
d second u dr squared plus--
no, is equal to l times l
plus 1 over r squared u.
And we're only interested
for this as r goes to 0.
And it's not an exact statement.
It's a discovery.
We're trying to discover
what's happening with the wave
function near r equals 0.
Well, this has two
kinds of solutions.
You can try a polynomial.
So this could go like
r to the l plus 1.
If you take two
derivatives, that works out.
You get the l plus 1 and l.
And it solves the equation.
Or r to the minus l also
solves the equation.
As you can imagine,
this is going
to be problematic in general.
It's too divergent.
It will not be possible to
normalize it, in general,
for arbitrary values of l.
So this is a very
brief analysis.
I'm not going into
all the detail
that probably this
deserves at this moment.
But this is ruled out,
and this is ruled in.
The only thing-- so it's true
that this one is ruled out,
and it has problems
for normalization.
It is too divergent as l.
But for l equals 0,
it's not divergent.
there's another reason
why this is not good.
It turns out that for l
equals 0 this doesn't quite
solve the Schrodinger equation,
the exact Schrodinger equation.
So the bottom line
of this analysis
is that we will have u of r
behave like r to the l plus 1
as r goes to 0.
And in particular, when
l is equal to 0, u of r
will behave like r.
So it will vanish
as r goes to 0.
So the only question is
how fast it vanishes.
It vanishes as r goes
to 0 for l equals 0.
It vanishes even
faster for higher l.
So it always vanishes, the
wave function at r equals 0.
And that's why we can
usually think of it
as having an infinite barrier.
The wave function could not
exist for r less than 0.
That physically doesn't exist.
And the boundary conditions are
such that that cannot happen.
All right.
We've finished the discussion
of the radial equation.
Now, our main interest with
the radial equation, of course,
is, at this moment,
the hydrogen atom.
So we're going to turn to that.